it sounds like one of the big
announcements plan for the upcoming
Final Fantasy 15 event may have been
uncovered early by a fan neogaf user
cupo nut I love this name by the way may
have uncovered something fans have been
clamoring for a surprise PC release for
the upcoming JRPG kupo nut dug around in
the event pages JavaScript and
discovered length placeholders for steam
and Windows 10 versions according to a
report from Game Zone plate holders can
also be found for Xbox one and ps4
additional findings show a few more
things that will reportedly be added in
the future including pages for a trailer
a schedule faq and livestream coupe
winnett notes that similar code was used
for the rise of the Tomb Raider page as
well there has not been an official
announcement of a pc version for Final
Fantasy 15 as the game is currently only
set for release on ps4 and Xbox one but
let's be real fans want it and director
Hajime Tabata has worked hard to honor
them I think it's safe to say this is
row this also wouldn't be the first time
a final fantasy game that wasn't an MMO
made its way to steam last year final
fantasy type-0 came to the platform and
we've gotten ports of final fantasy's 5
6 7 8 13 13 to lightning returns and
soon to be 9 as well for more juicy
details on Final Fantasy 15 you're in
the right place